bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en español tras 5 años de la firma del
acuerdo de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc fue presentado un informe sobre los
avances en lo que es la implementación
del enfoque de género de este acuerdo y
la ong colombia diversa hizo parte de
este grupo que realizó el informe y que
muestra el estado en que se encuentra la
implementación del acuerdo de paz para
garantizar los derechos de las personas
lgtb
víctimas del conflicto armado y es por
eso que nos acompaña laura beltrán
politólogo del área de paz de colombia
diversa quien participó precisamente en
la elaboración de ese informe laura
beltrán muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
quisiera preguntarle en primer lugar de
qué manera afectó el conflicto armado de
manera diferencial a la población lgp
gracias tengo por esa pregunta bueno el
conflicto armado hace todas las personas
elegir ente de manera diferencial porque
hay un contexto de prejuicio en la
realidad colombiana que es muy fuerte
entonces ese contexto de prejuicio
legítimo a la violencia contra las
personas del evidente y las expone en
mayor medida a los grupos armados además
los grupos armados han sabido aprovechar
ese prejuicio para conseguir fines de
guerra me refiero por ejemplo a cuando
los grupos armados hacia la exclusión de
las personas en el g20 de ciertos
territorios estaban a su vez afianzando
su control territorial y legitimándose
frente a la comunidad entonces digamos
que por eso y luego afectación de las
personas el gente ha sido mucho mayor
especialmente nos hemos encontrado en
colombia diversa las personas y lg han
sido castigadas expulsadas
instrumentalizadas por los actores
armados castigadas en ese sentido y por
ejemplo las familias que mandaban a sus
hijos de esos subsidios viana hacia las
farc para que éstas las corregirán
contra bajas forzadas lo que da cuenta
de nuevo el escenario de desprotección
que las personas se les desconocen estas
son a estos grupos e hicieron parte del
conflicto en colombia también fueron
expulsados no solamente ha sentido el
desplazamiento forzado sino
en el sentido del asesinato mismo y
podemos ver por ejemplo también en un
informe de que hicimos en tolima que el
patrón de violencia que encontramos fue
como un batallón del ejército matado a
las mujeres está claro para expresar el
prejuicio pero también para legitimarse
con la población esto mentalizados en el
sentido de que se considera que las
personas se les debe tesón de cierta
manera es por eso harán algunas labores
que los musulmanes si quieren o
necesitan mejor entonces las mujeres
trans por ejemplo también fueron
utilizadas y obligadas a fluir como
proxenetas mil markel convicto ahora a
la hora lo que son las violaciones a los
derechos de la población lgp te crees
que han sido menos visibilizadas durante
el conflicto armado y también tras el
acuerdo de paz y de ser así por qué
si han sido menos visibilizadas y es
gracias a este sistema de pensamiento en
el que normalizamos que de acuerdo a los
militares con los que nacemos tenemos
que vernos de una manera y que nuestro
deseo tiene que ser pues heterosexual
entonces eso está muy normalizado en la
sociedad colombiana y ha sido
una una arma que acusa con una forma de
una estrategia política que han usado
sectores conservadores y también pues
anti derechos contra los derechos de la
población lgp especialmente en el
acuerdo cuando se vote el plebiscito
el partido del presidente actual estuvo
hablando de la ideología de género y que
si el acuerdo tenía enfoque el gerente
que tenía y que tiene entonces la
sociedad se iba a homosexual izada
entonces dios por eso es que han sido
muy utilizadas violencias que las
personas y el gente que asumió en el
marco del conflicto y ahora en la
implementación nos hemos tenido
muchísimos problemas
para que las medidas para las personas
del g20 se cumplan sobre todo por falta
de voluntad política
ahora a la hora en el acuerdo de paz hay
cierta perspectiva de género de hecho
tiene más de 100 medidas de género pero
que dice explícitamente sobre la
población lgtb
listo santiago pues nosotros encontramos
leyes que mencionan directamente a la
población el gt a ningún todos
participación política 3 en el conflicto
que se relacionan en tanto el fin de
conflicto tiene que ver con las
garantías de seguridad y si no hay una
entidad de seguridad pues no hay
participación política
en este punto los los lineamientos de la
política de no estigmatización no
incluyeron las personas el gerente e
incluso a pesar de que las personas
participaron en este consejo tras el
participó todo y al final nos impidieron
las necesidades y las específicas de la
población el gmt también existe una cosa
que se llama el sistema integral de
garantías de seguridad para el ejercicio
de la política y tampoco incluyó a las
personas el gerente así como la comisión
nacional de garantías de seguridad
tampoco lo hecho entonces estamos viendo
como en este punto no se están
cumpliendo también encontramos para las
personas y el glp algunas medidas en
punto de drogas que tienen que ver sobre
todo por la estigmatización de los
consumidores y la atención a los
consumidores
pero de nuevo no hay las medidas por
ejemplo para hacia las personas el g20
ejecutiva de dos ilícitos puedan acceder
a las instituciones que sería lo más
importante en ese punto y en el punto de
víctimas es un tema integral tanto las
dosis predicción especial para la paz
como la comisión de la verdad y la
unidad busca de esas personas dadas por
desaparecidas tienen como ese mandato
especial e innovador para las
observaciones y transiciones de
garantizar los derechos de las personas
el genético
y bueno pues digamos esos son los puntos
en las que se menciona específicamente a
la población diferente pero por supuesto
que por ejemplo el punto 1 de reforma
rural integral debería incluirlos como
parte de las poblaciones vulnerables
históricamente discriminadas excluidas y
víctimas del conflicto armado ahora algo
que está muy bien explicado en el
informe de la hora es que en lo que es
la implementación del acuerdo entre la
población lgp y q hay algunos avances
estancamientos pero también muchos
incumplimientos cuales destacaría vos
bueno sobre avances destacaría en papel
que ayer avenida de búsqueda personal
dadas por desaparecidas incluyendo un
enfoque diferencial específico para las
personas lgtb con buscadores lg en los
territorios que también trata de hacer
frente a esta escogencia institucional
que hay desde desde las desde las
regiones de colombia hacia hacia el
sistema tradicional y en términos de
preocupaciones fuertes como te decía en
el punto 1 no hay medidas
para la sexual la tierra de las personas
y el g20 ni siquiera dentro del enfoque
o las medidas sociales para mujeres hay
medidas para la mujer y así hubiera el
bisexuales y trans tampoco a los
imperios nacionales y sectoriales que
son los encargados de hacer que las
personas en la realidad sean a servicios
como la salud el trabajo la alimentación
la vivienda ahí tampoco hay medidas para
las personas y el gmt y eso nos preocupa
especialmente porque nosotros vamos a
los territorios conocemos a las víctimas
y sabemos qué de la violencia que han
sufrido por el conflicto armado estas
personas se les está negando las
oportunidades todo el tiempo entonces es
importante que se le reconozcan los
derechos de las personas en el gp dentro
del punto 1 reforma rural integral que
no tienen medidas que estén funcionando
para las diversidades sexuales también
nos preocupan el punto de víctimas que
es algo que trabajamos nosotras muy de
cerca con la jurisdicción especial para
la comisión de la verdad el hecho de que
los parámetros mediante los cuales ellos
interpretan
y
contrastan las violencias que han
ocurrido en el conflicto armado no son
suficientes para demostrar el papel que
el género y la sexualidad han tenido en
el marco de la guerra que son todos
estos tipos de victimización es que te
contaba al principio
y además
digamos que los casos de la gente en los
macro casos entonces tienes esos macro
casos se supone que el enfoque de género
es tan transversal pero en realidad allí
no hay personas que hagan las preguntas
necesarias para estudiar la violencia
por prejuicio o por discriminación
contra las personas y lg vete ni tampoco
cosas como la violencia sexual a las
mujeres ya las personas 3 gmt las
violencias basadas en género entonces
como allí el estudio se queda corto y
nosotras desde colombia diversa y varias
organizaciones feministas que también
hacen parte en paz hemos estado
exigiendo
esta apertura del mar con ocasión
nacional de violencia sexual
reproductiva y otras violencias
motivadas la sexualidad el área de las
víctimas para qué puedas conocer lo que
ha pasado y trabajar por la no
repetición haremos ahora de un punto muy
crítico y es que los crímenes de líderes
sociales aumentaron precisamente desde
la firma del acuerdo de paz que suceden
ahora en particular con líderes
activistas lgtb
bueno las cifras de violencia contra las
personas en libertad en colombia
aumentaron se duplicaron de 2019 2020 y
bueno esto da cuenta primero de la
profunda exclusión que tienen las
personas desde la institución
institucionalidad como te decía a todos
los puntos de garantías de seguridad y
también de participación política no se
están implementando de manera efectiva y
no se está haciendo nada básicamente no
se están cumpliendo las leyes que el
acuerdo es sino para proteger a los
liderazgos sociales pero también la
particularidad de esos ataques a los
líderes del jerte es que son atacados
por ser el eje incluso cuando no están
defendiendo causas elegidos así es
también defendían un amor y el bienestar
común de la tierra por lamentar por ser
lesbiana porque se considera pues que no
debe existir primero y segundo que no es
no puede ser una persona al eje de un
referente público entonces es la salida
al espacio también nos está costando
muchísimo más aproximaciones de vettel
en colombia hablemos ahora de las
mujeres en particular son uno de los
sectores más vulnerables de la población
en estas zonas de conflicto más aún las
mujeres lesbianas trans o con
identidades disidentes están doblemente
golpeadas laura
exacto están doblemente golpeadas como
decía al principio el contexto de
prejuicio está ahí siempre y siempre
produce violencia contra las personas lt
pero en un contexto de conflicto armado
están en más expuestas a todos los
ataques de los grupos armados y a
silenciamiento de sus identidades y en
sus cimientos como sexuales a través de
la violencia el silenciamiento al
castigo o la mutilación y es
precisamente por eso que es necesario
que se cumplan en medio diferenciales
para la población y el xerez para
responder a todos esos derechos que se
han sido doblemente quitados a la
población y el gerente laura beltrán
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 a nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en france
24 punto confían con nosotros
[Música]